Gary what time do you wake up in the
morning huh my my discipline ideally
would be to get up super early in the
morning to me the most productive time
of day by far is early morning like 5
o'clock 5:30 6:00 would be late as it is
right now I've been working on a hectic
schedule so it means I get to bed a
little bit later so I've been getting up
around seven sevens pretty much my time
to get up when I'm writing the book or
when I'm doing something special then I
read Jake and I go to bed earlier and I
get up early getting in two to three
hours of productive time before the rest
of the world's awake is the most
delicious thing one can do for oneself
agreed why do you wake up in the morning
why do I wake up in the morning I wake
up the morning cuz I'm excited about
life because there's people and there's
ideas and there's explorations to be had
that day because I have my ideas about
what I want to get done but I'm not
arrogant enough to believe that those
have the necessarily the most important
are the only things that will happen
that day but I just have an innate
curiosity and I like to challenge myself
I'm more self competitive not so much
competitive with others so to me every
day is not opportunity to see
yeah the question really comes down to
one simple thing how do you make that
day matter how do you make that day
meaningful enough to be memorable I love
that that you're competitive
but not in the sense that we hear a lot
where you've got to be better than the
next guy which I know that that's true
but I like to talk about the difference
between self competition versus
competition with everyone out there or
perceived competition and then you end
up creating enemies or vice versa the
the downside the underbelly of being
competitive by nature is the traditional
definition of competition has you in a
perennial state of non success you just
can't win at it if I'm comparing my I do
CrossFit the exercise of choice at least
in this moment for me in the last year
year and a half has been CrossFit if I
were competing with those around me at
my gym my gyms one of the best in the
country
if I were competing against those in my
gym there's always going to be people
who are far far far more advanced far
superior athletically they their level
of fitness is off the charts they're
monkeys they're not even people so if I
were comparing myself to those people I
would I would always be in a deficit I'd
always be thinking what's missing what I
haven't accomplished right but if I'm
self competitive suddenly it flips the
script so now I'm looking at everybody
who's working on those 50 other people
30 other people 70 other people that are
working on at the same time and every
one of them is an opportunity to pick up
a trick and learn something and model
remodel something I learned more by
having relationships and dialogue and
just observing these other people so
that I can push myself further faster so
I I don't look I'm not in competition
with them I'm kind of in competition
with my own sense of well-being and
discipline and what how do I push myself
because I'll progress faster by not
competing than bike
was that always the case because I
noticed a lot of younger people are very
competitive
whereas I tend to see people maybe after
40 they tend to realize like you know
what no I think that it's more about my
goals and not comparing how well someone
else is doing over me yeah I think we
cut we all come out of the womb
competitive on some level academically
athletically in terms of our looks and
our social popularity and all sorts of
you know yeah absolutely and that's a
growing phase you know because there are
the passages I forget what they are
there's the the athlete and there's the
you know you grow into the Statesman and
then you go into the the community alter
whatever the wise person whatever those
are natural steps in our evolution is as
in this life journey and I think age has
a lot of advantages but underneath all
of that there's a sense that I'm okay
underneath all that is what I think is
that is is the key to success and
well-being not just professionally but
personally which is self belief it's
okay to like yourself it's okay to
believe in yourself it's okay to also be
patient and give yourself permission to
know that life is a process not an event
it's not about a report card because
that's a static idea it's a snapshot
that has nothing to do with your
aspiration your aspiration is so much
more it's so more more dimensional more
long-term it's a vision and if you don't
aren't driven by a vision and you're
only looking at it's like a corporation
looking at quarterly profits and not
doing the right thing long term what's
best for the company for the employees
for their stakeholders and for them and
and for the consumer they're totally up
posing views of life so if you have self
belief and if you can if you can if you
can really dig in and find within
yourself and celebrate that which is and
sometimes people can
people can because they forget who they
are people forget how amazing and unique
and special they are I had an emergency
room doctor years ago I was giving a
talk somewhere and he approached me
afterward and basically was very
lackluster very low-energy
complete complaining of himself that he
was tremendously average and I asked him
a few questions and it was shocking in
the span of a few moments what I learned
about this guy that was extraordinary so
he was responsible not only for being an
ER doctor which is already like oh my
gosh but he was responsible for this
large Hospital there was a series of
hospitals he was in charge of the
culture of the of the hospital chain all
incoming nurses all incoming doctors all
personnel at any stripe who came into
this system which is a system that
welcomes on a daily basis people in
trauma people in fear people in the most
crucial critical moment of their life
surrounded by family who are equally
concerned and upset and vulnerable so
he's the guy responsible for telling
teaching doctors and nurses and everyone
who's going to interface with the public
how to be better at what they do how to
be more humane at what they do how to
understand and be empathetic in ways
they might otherwise not have chosen to
be his impact on the lives of all the
doctors all the nurses not to mention
that thousands and thousands of
countless numbers of people who
trafficked through that environment on a
daily literally daily basis is
inestimable it is not susceptible of
measurement it is beyond enormity not
just because of the numbers of people
but because of the impossibility of
measuring how deeply crucial those
moments are and how they are
Mette here's a guy who thought he was
boring here's kinda thought I'm just
typical and average and what-have-you so
what I asked him to do is a personal
favor not really knowing me was if he
would go home and and and call upon
three nurses and three doctors currently
under the roof of this hospital and
three nurses and doctors who had he had
trained but had matriculated and going
on elsewhere in their life it's a dozen
people didn't have to be mathematically
precise reach out to these kinds of
people that you've had intimate
interaction with and ask them not to
respond in the moment but to be
thoughtful think about it and come back
to you if they're willing and tell you
the truth and the truth is the answer to
the following questions Who am I to you
what influence have I had in your life
how have you altered your view or or
habits or behaviors as a result of our
interactions what value do I represent
if any good bad or indifferent he called
me a month later he was like a changed
man he was ambulant he was his voice
went up in octave but he was excited he
was like oh my gosh I had no idea
who I was in the world in the eyes of so
many people I respect
anybody can do that exercise we just
don't think to do it going back to this
emergency room doctor and this gentleman
who is responsible for the culture of
this large Hospital how do you think
someone gets to that point where they
actually are truly amazing and they do
so much more than the average person
does but they see themselves as Seoul s
most successful people that I know
historically our fairly modest people
they're fairly humble people but there
are two categories of people people who
tried themselves for not being special
or successful despite their outward
success and those who embrace it I think
one thing most the majority of people
walking the planet have in common is
they take themselves for granted they
take their story for granted they don't
see what's truly innately special about
them and that's what their contribution
at the world or their community or their
family or their friends might be people
who brag people who are conceited who
are vain that's not ascribing the
outsized value to the truth of who they
are that's superficial that's an that's
an outside game not an inside game the
inside game is the truth of who each of
us is we're all so different
if I tell my story truly in a QA or
whatever environment people are gonna
reflect back to me things that I
ordinarily have brushed under the rug
and I'm caught up in the moment I'm not
even looking at where I've been in how I
got to this moment I think really
successful people come in all different
stripes some of them are very humble
because they understand how much work
went into it and it was a team sport
they didn't get there on their own and
and and I think what it comes down to
really in the sense is an age is a big
help in this is the secure person is is
is more modest a little bit more
interested in the other if you're more
interested himself you're a little bit
more braggadocio or you're a little bit
more vain or whatever that is your it
just says that you're a little bit less
secure it's not a terrible thing I'm not
judgmental and I don't see it as good
versus bad on a sliding scale
it's where each of us is on our path
learning to be a better version of
ourselves Gary do you live by a schedule
I live by a schedule not nearly so much
as I ought but I do I do have certain
things that I do in the morning more
morning more often than not that are
just personal private things that have
nothing to do with work that just set me
on a path toward a a more positive
action-oriented day that make me feel
good so they're there things some of
them are physical some of them are not
some of them are dietary some of them
are not
on a more macro scale I absolutely am
much more discipline now about making
sure that my schedule has holes in it
because I didn't use to used to a bead
that I was so busy morning tonight I
could work seven days a week every week
for weeks on end
now I ensure that I have time for
friends I have time for proper meals I
have time where I'll take you know time
to go to the zoo with my friend and then
their you know their kids or whatever it
might be so yeah I think I think because
the real work is not being busy the real
work is I'm a businessman and I'm a
creative person and both are essential
and I think that you know we all we all
have that experience if oh my god this
great idea came to me in the shower why
why did that come in the shower it came
in the shower or when you're swimming or
when you're distracted when you're doing
anything that completely removes you
from your normal thought process as
you're in the flow of work and taking
time off from work is probably the most
work productive thing you can do so a
lot of my inspiration comes from having
taken time away do you advise that to a
lot of let's say new people who arrive
in LA New York San Francisco where they
are so ready to like you know set the
world on fire and to kind of get their
you know accolades under their belt what
do you tell someone that maybe is just
starting out and is so hungry and going
back to younger people and being
competitive I I would I would its
moderated though because when you're
young and you're new and you're full of
vigor and you're just ambition is like
driving your every waking moment that's
okay go with it but within that let
allow diversity so if you're just doing
the same one thing repeatedly or if you
are for example if you're a writer and
all you do is stay home and write not
good it's not healthy
you know there's there's there's more
legs to the stool you've got to be out
making relationships and you've got to
be out learning the business you've got
to be out doing these other pieces of
the puzzle so the picture forms well you
can't just do one thing repeatedly and
hope for the kind of grand success that
you envision I don't think I think I
heard a quote one time from Jackie
Gleason and he said that his advice for
like famous people or people that had
kind of arrived in the industry was
don't stay in don't what don't stay in
don't stay inside don't isolate yeah
because that only leads to greater
things down the line and if you want to
take a look at something like maybe
Elvis who at toward the end of his life
I think was more isolated and things
like that so as a creative person you
know we want to think well we're working
on our craft or whatever it is that
we're doing and if we're out there
having fun then that's we're not being
true to why we came here everyone has
their own way and I do think that some
of the people I admire most some of the
things I had I appreciate about my own
life is the the persistent consistent
driver that is creativity in my life I'm
a learner I am an addict so whether it's
books or people conversations or
documentaries or whatever it might be or
travel or and travel could be you know I
was just in Europe or I was just in
Nepal or I was just or it could be
traveling in this beautiful Los Angeles
that is my my little planet because
there's so many layers and so many
opportunities some of which align
perfectly with my work and some of which
have nothing to do with it but inform me
as a human being and I do think that
like I had a liberal arts education in
college the broader my inputs the better
off I am
I think getting to narrow
in two routine in your pursuits is
probably not a success formula for most
carry out of the best scripts that
you've read in your life and of those
that have been made into films on
average how long has it been between the
time that you read the script and the
time that the movie came out kind of
came to fruition oh gosh a long time
from the time that I've held a script in
my hand whether I'm the producer and I
put it on the big screen or someone
else's it was someone else's child to
raise the the length of stay between
script and and an actual produced film
varies so dramatically and it's not
necessarily based on budget but but
there are so many it's one of the most
collaborative media one can imagine you
know if I'm a fine artist I can paint a
painting without permission today but if
I want to make a film and I want to make
a film for let's say a million dollars
or a hundred million dollars or five
hundred thousand dollars I need a lot of
inputs and I need a lot of preparation
my films the past I actually did several
films what I consider to be a breakneck
pace which was three years from script
to screen pretty woman was three years
under siege was three years there was
there was a couple of Indies that were
less and some studio films that were
longer but but there is no there is no
proper standard every film dies a
thousand deaths some of them are deaths
by paper cuts and some are death by
massive train wrecks and then you
resuscitate you move on and
and you know forrest gump reportedly was
I don't know 13 or 15 years between
script and screens so you never there's
no there's no rule what is the best way
for a writer to make a living as a
writer in today's age 2017 doing
rewrites you know I think I think the
best way for if I were a writer today if
I were entering the business today or I
were in the business today as a writer
as a professional writer I think there
are several things assuming you know
listen if you're David Kelly and you
have that level of success you already
know your path but if you're not yet
David Kelly or you're not yet the
equivalent of that on the future films
on whatever that might be if you don't
have that little trophy on your shelf I
think one of the great things you can do
for yourself is to be more and
diversified I know that that's probably
contrary to old-school thinking which
says specialize become the best at one
thing and known for one thing but I
think we are all today brands each and
every one of us is brand building and to
the extent that we can that involves
audience it involves public it involves
our colleagues in the business and so if
you happen to be a writer and you want
to do TV and film that's okay if you
want to do you know apart from TV and
film if you want to be writing a blog
that's okay if you want to be looking at
creating alternative content or let's
just say a TV series what I won't use
the word TV if you want to create a
series on YouTube I absolutely applaud
it because today the rules are out the
window and people are looking for their
talent in every conceivable corner every
nook and cranny and a lot of that is
social media a lot of it is the
unexpected and and and the same is true
in Reverse if you're selling ideas
you're no longer limited to selling the
ABC CBS and NBC or on the future side to
Paramount Warner Disney Universal etc
you have all of these other sort of
counterculture approaches or or the new
Hollywood
Kewell and it's Hulu and it's Amazon
it's Netflix and it's it's it's Redbox
and it's all these other companies that
have real meat on the bone real
distribution real capital and and and
then brands you know there's all these
relationships with brand driven stuff on
on on social platforms so I think the
key question is not is is to understand
who you are as a greater where you
properly can succeed where you are
excited and where you think your
audience lives and consider those
alternatives to while you're writing
your Oscar candidate of a screenplay or
whatever that thing is
how does someone find out which realm
they're best in TV film well what you
what you want to be and what you're good
at
or often at odds you know I mean I'd
love to be LeBron James I'd love to be
yo-yo ma I'd love to be a lot of people
but those aren't mine what's mine is
based on my skillsets my experience what
what excites me what interests me what
when my voice goes up an octave it's
because I'm in a conversation that I
find absolutely irresistible know that
about yourself for some people that for
the lucky ones what excites you is what
you do if it's not but the beauty of a
screenwriter or a writer in general all
writers it doesn't matter whether it's
books or TV or film or any kind of read
if you're a writer you can choose to
write about anything you can be the
person that you wanted to be without
being it you can make that area of
inquiry substantively your world
so is it creative you have a little bit
more freedom than most people do out in
the workplace but I think if you pay
attention to what excites you
and sometimes you just got to ask other
people what do you think excites but you
know me really well
ask ask yourself ask others ask source
whether I'm a screenwriter or some other
form of creative I think one of the key
disciplines is to understand the
discipline is key and that is to say
when you when you you you should find
out what works best for you are you a
morning person are you a late night
writer I I'm I'm not creative late at
night I like being up but I'm not create
I write like a fiend when I when I have
that early morning coffee because all
night it's been percolating for me
that's not true for everybody but if
that's who you are then make damn
certain you've gone to bed at a
reasonable hour and then you're up and
you've done gotten your stuff done and
now at 6:00 in the morning or 7:00 in
the morning or whatever it is you set
aside and you turn your phone off and
you have absolutely sort of put these
profound proof walls around you
literally and figuratively so that you
have two to three hours have an
intensely productive time on a
consistent daily basis if you do that
because it's a game of inches and if you
do that instead of being the person
who's laboring over a script and
rewriting it three years and you know
non-stop or you're doing a lot of first
drafts and you're on your 12th script
this year those are not the indicators
of success but if you're someone who's
got that kind of discipline and you say
how much can i how much can I improve
this we know that rewriting is writing
but up to a point you know so how many
drafts you know if I can do this every
day and then I set it aside move on to
the next one I may come back to that
with proper inspiration but if you do
that what you can accomplish in a short
one year period will put to shame most
people who don't have that discipline
who don't know themselves and give
themselves a framework
to be productive Gary what's the
greatest script you've ever read and
what happened to that script
you know I've read a lot of what I would
consider I've been blessed to read a lot
of great scripts and some of them never
got made fortunately many have I
remember reading the million dollar
hotel by a friend of mine necklace Klein
and I was so bottomed endlessly in love
with that script and I wanted him to
direct he'd never directed it ended up
being directed by Ben venders and in my
estimation I it was not it was it it
didn't have the poetry that was Nicolas
that was infused and in it because of
who he was no disrespect of a vendor's
he's a you know lauded filmmaker of
course and but but so you know in that
case it kind of went one direction
pretty woman before it was pretty woman
3000 by jf Lawton was certainly I
certainly at that time it was the best
script I had ever held in my hands and
it was a dark drama of course but it was
absolutely riveting compelling beautiful
in a in a in a sort of you know tragic
sense and of course as we know that film
did get made only it got and and and
ironically the film got made so true to
its original form but just the structure
and the characters in that I was so
taught that we didn't have to labor too
hard to turn it tonally and of course we
had Garry Marshall so he could improv
anything yeah he filmed it as it was and
then he did a little improv and we found
that sort of comedy in it so that got
made again in a totally unexpected
direction originally it was going to be
a dark independent you know few million
dollar film so you never know these
things always take left turns news
and but there have been a lot of great
scripts but you know sadly that didn't
get made I remember there was a little
film called The Cure that I was madly in
love with the very special care and
little small script young characters and
I had actually shared that with Steven
Spielberg and his people flipped out and
then Steven fell in love with it and we
were cranking up the the offer from
Universal and Universal and Warner
Brothers simultaneously and and the the
agent actually sold the script overnight
to a third party and it got made years
later as a low-budget kind of non-event
that was the biggest heartbreak
personally for Mary but you know you
never know there are scripts that and
there probably some scripts today that
will stand still haven't been made that
will get made but I thought that I think
are amazing that just you there's no
there's no predicting this business so
what was it about that script that you
said was eventually sold to a third
party I mean what was it that just
really resonated with you was just a
personal thing that you thought that you
felt a connection to or the way it was
written the voice of the protagonist it
it what was so remarkable about it was
there are there are characters and
stories that are so gorgeous
because of their truth because they call
to us they penetrate us in a way that's
undeniable that we have all of us had
that experience growing up and this was
about growing up young characters and
any anyone who has blood flowing through
their veins would have recognized some
part of themselves or their friends in
that story in a very poignant context
and and because it was so Universal and
so sweetly done not it wasn't a sweet
picture it was it was a challenging
story but at what was sweet about it was
the the attention to detail the truth of
how it played out
before I moved to LA I was an attorney
in San Francisco
it was a very respected position it was
a beautiful city I had a great life I
had a nice income I was set and I was
deeply comfortable and it scared the
hell out of me
had I stayed I knew for certain about me
not true of all lawyers not true of all
people what have you I knew for me I was
gonna wither from the inside but that
was not the right life choice for me on
a soul level on a spirit level not a
role level or a gold level but on a soul
level it was I had to leave I had to
flee I had to run away literally and so
I did and I ran away and I wasn't sure
exactly how it was going to work out but
I thought I'm gonna go to the far end of
the state to this crazy place called LA
where I knew nobody and I was going to
pursue getting into the film business
because I so love storytelling I'd grown
up inside of books I was a lover of
story and most of my friends and
colleagues and certainly the other
attorneys in the firm I worked at at the
time they all wagged their finger at me
and said how can you do that that's so
brave you're the I or or crazy or
something we don't understand and I said
to them it's not brave it's the opposite
it's it's it's survival
that for me to survive and thrive I
can't stay here this is unsafe for me
and it's unsafe because it's so
comfortable I need to go to this foreign
land called Los Angeles I need to go to
a place where I'm anonymous and know
nobody I need to stretch my limbs I need
to see if I can make it in this very
highly competitive unknown world to me a
filmmaking because that lights me up
from the inside out I may fail I may
come crawling back on my knees begging
you to take me back old friends of San
Francisco but on the other hand if I
don't do it I will never know and I'll
always regret it that's one version of
many many many stories I could tell
about and that's just me
but I've seen it across most of the
people of who who've been a part of my
life that this thing called the comfort
zone is the most dangerous a zip code
you can live in because it's limiting by
definition you get inured you become
habit driven you become you notice less
you become busy with that which is
familiar and you build invisible walls
around that experience that becomes your
longitude and your latitude as opposed
to self-defining us an adventure as an
explorer as someone who is going to be a
maverick and do the things that truly
truly express more deeply who you are
and that cannot be the same thing when
you're 17 as it is when you're 40 as it
is when you're 80 we are designed to
evolve we are designed to change the
world changes whether we like it or not
it's good of us to understand that
that's something to be embraced and it's
like our friend it's not our enemy it's
not poison to our spirit it's the
opposite it's an elixir
I've had multiple careers and I don't
think I'm done yet you know and that's
why because I can't predict what my
appetites will be 24 months from now or
five or ten years from now I know what
I'm doing right now is exciting to me
but it always involves exploration it
always involves and and I say that not
as a necessarily as a physical reality
but it's an emotional psychological
educational reality you know like who
how can I be a better version of me
that's the job really for all of us in
life how do we become a better version
of ourselves and since we spend a
majority of our waking hours in the
service of this thing we called work and
livelihood boy what a great tapestry to
make sure that what you're doing expands
you
so let's say someone has made a bold
move to come from wherever to LA in New
York one of these major cities but then
they've been here several years and now
they're in a new kind of rut new kind of
comfort zone yeah I'm going out I'm
submitting fill in the blank of whatever
it is they're submitting but it's habit
driven and it's not really going
anywhere and they feel stagnant but
everyone else hey they're here in this
big city or wherever and they're
supposedly working there supposedly
getting stuff out there how do you shake
that up and I know I'm being a little
bit vague but let's just say they're
here it's not very okay if you want to
learn to play tennis find yourself a pro
that's the game that's how you improve
the problem most creatives have when you
know they they they come to LA they come
to New York they go wherever they are
and they what do they do
most of them learn bad habits why
because they're learning and mimicking
like people around them I have an actor
I'm following what other actors are
doing I'm asking them I'm learning from
them and yet they're not at the top of
the totem Sam with writers same with
producer same with it doesn't matter
human beings writers as one example I
get query letters every day line query
letters
dear so-and-so it could be my name it
could be creative executive it could be
my name misspelled it could be anything
dear so-and-so log line short
description you know can I send you a
script I'll sign a release sign John
that's what I get
repeatedly all day long in my inbox
there is not one lick of research there
is not one look of anything personal
like why is this the writer the only
writer who could have written this story
why was it so compelling that they chose
this out of all the stories in one's
imagination why did they choose to send
it to me now I don't want to receive the
agony and ecstasy as a letter but
something I drop a kernel something that
stands out and makes them makes me think
makes me react makes me wonder about
this but they don't I can promise you
not even 1% do what I'm describing so
this is what writers learn from other
writers it could be actors learning from
other actors etc they learn the habitual
tried-and-true day-to-day protocol which
is usually very unsuccessful the ROI the
return on investment in sending blind
query letters is gonna be horribly
frustrating if you're a business you'd
be bankrupt so why do it you do it
because this is what other people are
doing you need to associate with with
more successful people and you need to
think about it differently if you were a
fashion designer and you took that
approach you focus on your craft focus
on your craft focus on your craft and
send out letters saying here's my
designs aren't I great you'd never have
a brand you have to think in terms of
business you have to think in terms of
what what more could I do that others
aren't doing as opposed to what they are
doing how do I stand out so separating
yourself out from the herd is definitely
the name of the game
and anyone who's invested all that blood
blood sweat and tears that sort of soul
equity investing all that time writing a
hundred and twenty or ten pages of
whatever of story and rewriting it till
it's just so but they want to share
their wares with the world now they're
so proud of this they should they should
invest a like amount of time in figuring
out how to market and how to be a
business person and how to reach out to
people how to do things differently than
all their peers like that's a great
measurement am i doing what everyone
else is doing or am I being somehow
putting myself out into the world and
speaking of myself to the right people
in ways that matter you mentioned
fashion had me thinking of Diane von
Furstenberg and her wrap dress and how
it was this dress that no one had really
ever seen it and it fit every body type
it made every body type look good so I
just don't know you're talking about
fashion size kind of thinking about that
how many times do we see artists leave
jobs Johnny Cash you know I mean Lady
gaga
you know I mean it's there's a million
ways to stand out every creative person
should consider themselves primarily
responsible for the success of their
career is that true it is an absolutely
true statement that every credit person
needs to be that primarily responsible
person who stewards their own career
who's the architect it's great if you
have others with their oars in the water
helping you it's great if you have an
agent it's great if you have a manager
if you have an attorney if you have
other people who are mentors or wear
different hats in your life who
contribute strategy time effort money
whatever all those things are all
contributions smart and well intended
contributions are welcome of course but
the statement that we hear so often from
a creative if only I had an agent is an
unfortunate statement in my view because
even when you have when you're still a
hundred percent responsible when I was a
personal manager representing primarily
writers and directors some actors but
when I was a literary manager my
attitude was first I had to deal with my
writer you work as hard at being a
writer as I work as being your
representative and we're gonna get along
great but by the way you're still a
hundred percent responsible for your
career and by the way so am i I'm a
career and when we get you an agent
the agents a hundred percent responsible
for your career now we got three hundred
percent
sounds like the producers but it's true
I could never allow anyone to be even
one percent responsible or I wasn't
doing giving my all so when they get an
agent when they get a manager when they
get people who want to jump on board
that's great but it's frosting it's not
the cake they have to be the one because
you know what at the end of the day it's
their personality it's their talent it's
their signature in the world
that is gonna win the day an agent can
only open a door make an introduction
set the table but the writer or the
actor or whomever has to walk into the
room literally and metaphorically and
win the day it has to be their vision it
has to be their voice and has to be
their style it has to be their
personality and energy that seduces the
universe into saying yeah I want to play
with you your dreams gonna get you and
make you we're gonna we're gonna make
your dream come true because what you
bring with you not because your agent
said X or your manager did why that's
not the truth the truth is they just
opened a door which by the way you could
have opened on your own had you
understood that you could open it on
your own but yeah the talent can't just
be the talent the talent has to
understand even if ap it's not about how
many hours a day they invest on the
business side of their life it's it's
more deeper it's deeper than that it's
an understanding that I'm going to well
this into being I'm going to well people
into my life who are gonna help me I'm
gonna we'll new relationships into my
life I'm gonna take action that pays
dividends so if you had a performer or a
writer what have you in your chair and
you're they're sort of slumped down and
they're saying you know this just isn't
working and I have this agent a manager
and they're not sending me out or
they're not you know whatever it's they
that they're putting the blame on thing
the other person what would you say to
them make them wrong show them how it
gets done you want to complain about
your agent your manager not getting you
auditions or whatever it happens to be
great show them how to kick up some dust
and get yourself the audition
it's not okay to sit home and complain
you know the glass doesn't happen
do you ever ever ever ever you know
we're all well we're all allowed our
moment we're all allowed to have that
one day or that preferably that one hour
right then you have to dust yourself off
and say success is about moving on with
it and if other people aren't getting it
done for you then then you've got to
motivate them and the best way to
motivate someone is to show them what
they're not doing by doing it yourself
there's a wonderful quote it's escaping
me at the moment a great science fiction
writer I believe it was who said you
know you can't you can't allow your
manuscripts to to to gather destined in
a dresser drawer
let's talk about marketing a screenplay
when does it happen
how important is it how does the
screenwriter do it effectively it's not
important it's essential it's crucial it
is life-affirming and it is absolutely
the responsibility of any talent any
creative to market themselves if it's a
writer and there's a script or a book or
some some some product time to market it
that's what you've got to do and here's
what most people don't understand it
should be and it is fun it's fun if I
take that same writer to a cocktail
party and I put a drink in their hand
and say tell these people they're
fascinated by you and what you do talk
about that they're gonna talk non-stop
they will you will not be able to shut
them up but if you on the other hand say
ah you've got a script you're at home
pick up the phone and call someone no
they don't want to do it suddenly
marketing is a negative it's a bad thing
it's all in how you perceive it
marketing and sharing your talent with
the world should be a joy it should be
your purpose the problem is people think
so narrowly 99.9% of writers who have a
screenplay ready to go to market they've
rewritten it it's ready they've tested
it beautiful what do they do they
automatically think I need to send it to
agents I need to send it to producers
and then they stop the thought ends oh
my gosh that does sound like not a lot
of fun because who are the people
getting all the scripts producers and
agents I would look at it and say let me
research this what are the kinds of
projects that are exciting that have
been produced successful projects that
people love that are similar over the
last handful of years whether it's TV
film or whatever
and I'll make a list and I'll do a
spreadsheet I'll list the
cinematographer in the editor and the
script supervisor in the casting
director and everybody but the producer
in the agent and I will start calling
them and reach out to their assistants
and saying I'm calling because oh my god
you guys were involved with one of the
favorite projects of all time I so
admire the work and I have something
spiritually very similar I love your
advice would you be my 5-minute mentor
would you play with me on this a little
bit there are endless conversations that
you can have you develop rapport with
people because you share a common
interest that's the key and if you can
get them interested in the conversation
then you can get them soon on the third
call interested in reading your script
they're not asking anything of them when
you call an agent you're asking them to
represent you that's a huge ask when you
send your script to a previous you're
saying will you produce this oh my god
that's the biggest task of any because
what that means is that the bridge has
to invest several years of on their own
dime to create value and make this a
reality when you ask an agent to
represent your producer proves your film
you have to understand there's almost
nothing in it for them at the outset
they're going to invest their time and
their belief in their relationships on
your behalf for no money that's the
reality but if you make it about
something else if you make it about a
shared common interest that's exciting
and fun and those people can become your
ambassadors and backdoor that script
over to that agent or that script ever
it comes in a different package it comes
in a different content
that's where magic happens that's where
else can be kick sit I could talk about
that for about three days Gary I sense
from you such like an open abundance
mindset did you always think like this
did you always feel like things were
unlimited that there was no there was no
but a lot of us just think in terms of a
box myself included
it's and I I don't see that from you I
see that you see endless possibilities
and there's never a black-and-white
answer there's a lot of gray my world is
entirely grey there's no black and white
and it is about endless possibility it's
it's what you make of it I came to
Hollywood wide-eyed rose colored glass
and by the way I'm still wearing
rose-colored glasses I will be the
eternal optimist till the day I leave
this life because it's a better choice
for me
but when someone since noted the thing
about moving to LA to try and get in the
film business they spent years getting
know a lot of knows hundreds of
thousands of knows and a very rare
instance I might get a yes but the nose
so outweighed it you know it's
interesting there was a book by Jeff
Olson called this the slight edge and in
that book he talks about social science
studies have proven that a child by the
age of five has heard the word know
forty thousand times and he's heard that
same child has heard the word yes by
eight to eight thousand times forty
thousand knows eight thousand yeses five
times the gravity holding that child
down as the buoyant yes uplifting that
child's mindset and sense of possibility
that's a formative time so they enter
the first grade with with that energy
quite a deficit there imagine the
possibility if that were reversed
how would that kid enter into so into
India into his social a new social
environments but be that as it may I see
the world as endless possibility when
someone says no to me I've heard it so
many times that I've gone deaf I am
literally depth to the word so to me
when you say no to me I'm smiling and
I'm excited why because it's the same as
he yes I choose it to be the same as he
yes why I know that no is not yes but
what I do know is that the greater
currency whatever you were gonna say yes
to it would have been nice it would have
made me happy but the real win is my
relationship to you with you so if I can
take that no and honor you by saying
fantastic first of all I've taken all
the you know people don't like to say no
it makes them feel terrible and they
feel guilty and that's nothing but if I
take that away right off the table by
going oh my god great and surprised them
well new new rules right so I can say
that that's fabulous you know it would
you have no idea the value that you
would bring to my life that you would
honor me if you would be my my three
point seven minute mentor right now my
five minute mentor if you can share with
me why this is a no to you I would be
eternally grateful
now you've you've opened the door to
them telling you the truth they're not
gonna say no you flattered them you've
honored them you've made them smile
hopefully made them laugh and you're
being honest and they know that we know
when someone's being honest with us and
now out comes the thing called empathy
and that thing called caring so they'll
tell you and a you will learn something
important and be that ineffable thing
happens we as two people have just
bonded in an entirely higher context
I've left the room with an O and a
friend an O and a closer relationship
and a new mentor
you do that a hundred times over the
course of a couple of years success is
inevitable because people who care about
you who are more successful will ensure
that that's the way that's the way it
works
have you had an O then come back a year
two three whatever later and say you
know what Gary remember we talked I was
just wondering I this this is different
from when we last you know and and it
kept the relationship or it kept the
meeting in a good standing there was no
negativity kept it upbeat and then they
came back to you and it turned out there
was something else that they thought of
you for how you approach people
determines how they feel about you not
just in the moment but ongoing I have
had a lot of people every time come back
with opportunity in a different form a
different time a different place a
different topic a different project if
you will and invite me into a
conversation that was largely the result
of earlier interactions and those
interactions left them with a positive
feeling I didn't make them feel bad I
quite the opposite and
you know that's that that's what success
looks like to me success to me looks
like a string of pearls human
relationships that were dealt with well
in the moment because now people are
talking about me behind my back but in a
good way
or thinking about me perhaps in a better
way and and and then remembering me
because of it and and I think we all do
that we we like we like to do business
with people that we like that we respect
that we trust that we know how they're
going to behave if I deliver bad news to
you and you come back in a positive way
to me I know that you're the writer I
want in a red room at 3 a.m. in the
morning when things are really tough and
getting ugly and I can count on you to
still be a human being that does matter
you will always get hired over the
slightly more talented writer if I don't
trust that to be true about them but I
do trust that to be true about you
that's how we're wired let's talk about
planning and I think you've said in your
book starting without a plan is a recipe
for frustration confusion and failure do
most people plan for their entertainment
careers I mean did you plan when you
left San Francisco been an attorney
you're used to planning out probably
your schedule and all the caseloads that
you're gonna be talking to for the day
or maybe not I don't know but but
structure is very important to an
attorney's work I know so you come here
thinking it's gonna be a different world
were you planning or did is that
something you learned over time you know
I don't think I was at the outset I
don't think I was that different from
others who embark on a creative career I
had been an attorney yes where there's
an inordinate amount of study in
preparation and discipline and
and you scheduled your life out and you
walk into you open a door called
creativity and everything suddenly seems
mysterious and random and chaotic and
uncertain then there's no footprints in
the sand or so it seems and I think
that's true for most people it was a
little it was certainly true for me to
an extent until you realize and
hopefully you do quickly come to realize
that's not true that there are
footprints in the sand that a lot of
people have come before you and all you
have to do is think of it as as a
business and if you do you will save
yourself a lot of time because you'll
take all the wonder and mystery and
anxiety bit and say oh people have done
this for decades and decades yeah
there's some new technology and there's
you know we're using different kinds of
editing equipment but fundamentally the
the the human experience is the human
experience when I learned that oh I can
choose to be a manager and I can you
know that I I started to develop the
rigor of discipline right and say oh I'm
going to have this many meetings today
and I'm gonna have an office and I'm
gonna have
I'm going to adopt certain practices
then it started allowing me to really
flourish until then I was just sort of
rambling around talking to random people
about random things hoping for some
spark of enlightenment some inspiration
but I think you have to sort of and
begin to anchor yourself batten down the
hatches and say no I know I want to be a
writer I know I want to be an actor I
want to be a producer whatever I want to
be and I am going to mimic and I'm gonna
learn from it again it's the same thing
we were talking about before I'm gonna
reach out to some people and ask them to
be my 5-minute mentor and I'm gonna ask
myself to mimic what I learned from them
and started to develop that as a as a
rigger as a habit as a discipline set
set guardrails down so that I know that
I'm moving in one direction forward in
terms of planning where do you think
people go wrong like I see a lot of
people and myself included the day gets
away from them and that's something I've
really had to work on for myself and
I've seen a lot of other people too
because we're creative we go with what
feels good we go on a whim a spark well
there's a galaxy not a world of
difference between planning and it to-do
lists a to-do list is useless
because any any slight breeze will blow
it away anything can interfere with that
because you're not committed to it it's
not a plan it's just a list it's like a
shopping list maybe I'll even get to the
grocery maybe I will when you have a
plan it means that I'm gonna prioritize
the things that really matter to me if
if nothing else I'm gonna get these
three things done and I'm gonna get them
done first not second or third or fourth
I'm gonna get them first my morning is
going to be consist of a B and C I don't
even set meetings usually until the
afternoon because I need the morning
hours to do what I need to do what I
promised myself the things that I've
planned because the night before and
that's part of my discipline so the
night before I make a call sheet I make
a list what did the top priorities yes
there's a bunch of calls I could make
and some other things I
could do and will eventually get around
to but these are the three or the five
or the two or the seven inviolable
things these will get done tomorrow so
I'm gonna put them at the top of my my
agenda I'm gonna start on them early in
the morning and by lunch time they
should be done what happens the
afternoon can happen to flow I can be
spontaneous I can say oh forget that I'm
gonna do this but if you if you if you
haven't anchored yourself in a plan and
it and that plan is not only what are
you gonna do but what are you gonna do
it and you know how are you going to
structure your day and how do you have a
value system how do you how do you know
to say yes or no to that person do I go
to a coffee meeting with this person
nine times out of ten I'm going to say
no because it doesn't rank high enough
on my list and value you talked about
too in your book I think people keeping
busy and so it seems like they're doing
things they're working toward their
career but in actuality they're spinning
wheels they're they're kind of wasting
time what are some of those things that
we often think that hey you know I'm out
here I'm working hard at this you know
how you doing son how you doing you know
yeah whatever daughter in you out there
work oh yeah I'm meeting with people I'm
doing this and doing that I'm pitching
this I think most of it most of us are
really I think unfortunately miss
educated
and we're taught to delude ourselves
the person who's super busy is important
they're on their way to something big as
opposed to the person who's productive
which may not look busy at all you know
there's an old there's an old idea that
has been around since the dawn of time
which is that we should we should spend
less time doing and more time imagining
seeing clear as a bell about which we
want to occur in our lives and that
could be the person I want to meet the
amount of money I want to make the kind
of home I want to live in
I mean imagine it down to the finest
nuance in detail in Technicolor I would
rather spend an hour in the morning
imagining envisioning than being so busy
doing little tasks that I forget where
I'm going I forget my direction so busy
is busy is not something to be applauded
in my world being productive is and
sometimes being productive and busy
happened at the same time you know when
you're in production you are busy but
you also know that it's mapped out that
day you're gonna get all your shots on
your shot list you're gonna look at
dailies you're gonna take these kinds of
creative meetings that's busy but you're
also being productive if they go
together
hallelujah but unfortunately I think a
lot of us and I've been guilty of it in
the past
God knows of being so busy then I sort
of forgot what was important what I
really needed to get done and I
certainly didn't wasn't thinking about
is this line up with my with my ultimate
vision this is like creative
visualization like Shakti Guan I'm
saying her name wrong but is she a book
on that yeah I suppose I mean I've never
never been when to do vision boards or
you know
but you think but but thinking it's
about manifestation and sort of law of
attraction I mean you're thinking yeah
listen I you know a lot of that Sussman
what's the hijacked I mean it's it's
just been repackaged in these new-age
you know do the vision board do this do
that it's as old as the hell's this is
it goes it's it's part it's part of
mysticism every mystical tradition has
some form of this silver thread woven
into the fabric of their belief just to
follow up on what we were talking about
you know there's two schools of thought
you have people that say you can't be so
precious about the work you can't hold
it so tightly and be so paranoid and
then you have someone like a Steve Jobs
who was incredibly secretive
you wouldn't know sometimes what was
coming out or there were you know rumors
amidst Apple whatever and we wouldn't
know until years later sometimes with
things which obviously worked out for
him in many ways so it's an interesting
mix how do we kind of go in the middle
where we're not too paranoid too
precious I mean I see sometimes
filmmakers won't even have their their
trailer embeddable they they won't even
make it so people can embed them on it
on uh someone else's website because
they're they're afraid or whatever maybe
they just didn't click the button but to
that level versus someone that's an open
book that is unfortunately easily taken
advantage of and I'm not saying that
happen in your case but I mean believing
in the good of people because they're
good you know I think there's there's a
fine line yeah I mean I look there's two
sides to every idea
and and and one is knowing the time in
the place so for example a lot of
filmmakers hold their cards so close to
their vast or their shares that it's
self-defeating classic example most
studio executives in the marketing
department will tell you that they are
considered Satan by filmmakers
filmmakers will not share one iota about
their film one frame of their film until
it's absolutely locked and loaded which
means that the marketing department has
precious little time to really think
about and be creative and come up with
great concepts and execute on those it's
a last minute 11th hour deal and it
almost always is right is that in the
filmmakers best interest I suspect not I
know that when many many years ago I did
a picture at Universal young
writer-director his first directing gig
and together we went in and with
storyboards and we and I and I insisted
that we have someone from every
department president or two people from
every department whatever can show up we
had like 16 or 18 people in the room
representing every conceivable area of
marketing and we presented to them and
said look we just came to say hi we want
to know what you do and we want you to
be aware of our little project because
it's not the biggest on your lot and so
if you quit we just want to share with
you a little bit about than Genesis the
history of the project we want to share
some storyboards by the way the
storyboard suck and you guys are so much
smarter but it was just some way we
could communicate to you
but most importantly before we leave
after we've shut up and we've had some
QA what we really want from you is we
want your guidance telling us while
we're out on location shooting what do
we need to bring back what do you need
to do your job better
what kind of still images what kind of
b-roll you what do we need to bring to
you so that you can be the best they
literally said to us we're veterans
we've been here 15 years 20 years 25
years 30 years whatever we've never ever
had filmmakers conduct this kind of a
meeting that was at Universal Pictures
Wow okay so there there's there is there
is clearly this sort of tradition in in
in the human race to hold very very dear
to keep very private are what we
consider our IP our baby
and I think sometimes it serves some
sometimes it's self-defeating
you know it's you know but I I think you
just have to sort of be sober about it
and and and you know look at what other
successful people do and how they do it
and the flip side of that is I never
worry that much about people stealing
what I have I have this crazy idea that
each of us is so gifted and special in
the way that we would do something that
no one could steal any of my ideas and
and do it the way I would do it let them
let them do their version of it No
so I can write a book or I can produce a
movie or I can I can nurture a recording
artist or whatever those things are an
idea is worth very very little in
Hollywood it's the people and and and
and and their ability to deliver on an
idea and birth out of nothing that's
what we do we birth out of thin air
something very concrete very compelling
hopefully that moves people happily or
sadly I think it's the doer not the idea
so I think theft is actually an
interesting concept in a world of IP and
I don't really take out an insurance
policy I don't worry about it I don't
think about it
Gary what do you think is the biggest
mistake a screenwriter can make I think
I don't know about the biggest mistake a
writer can make there are a lot of
mistakes writers can and do make one of
them is being a bit inebriated and and
and to grand about their work in the way
they communicate it to the world no one
wants to people want to discover they
want to be Columbus discovering the new
world and if you
overstate the new world and that you've
already developed and belt hotels and
what they're gonna find and they should
come and it takes all the fun out of
being they've discovered the Christopher
Columbus so I would say be you know be
authentic be persuasive but but don't
overstate I think another mistake that
writers can make is believe in the other
people no more than you
believing that other people know the
right way to do things are a better way
to do things just like know you know
yourself you know your project better
than anyone and you should if you check
with your gut in your brain both be
fully capable and competent to figure
out the best way to put that out into
the market market it and tell the story
around it no one can be you I mean III
think there are a lot of mistakes that
writers can make one of them is is is
wasting time and not being as
disciplined as they should be about
their output one of them is certainly
thinking that there's such a thing as
perfection hogwash you know
you there's there's a point at which I
know people have been rewriting a book
or a script or something for literally
years plural and that's not a good sign
so I think there's a you know look all
of us are capable of making lots of
different kinds of mistakes I think
common sense sort of is the answer to
most of them well I mean Susan Cain
she's an attorney and she wrote quiet
yeah and she talked about how she took
seven years I think to work on the book
but she loved the process and that was
part of her being an introvert and
that's what the book is about as is is
just delving into sort of this own were
her own little world and writing and
researching and all that was so
seductive to her
whereas knowing that she had to get it
out there well that was something that's
the total sort of art her it's hard to
introvert me cringe at that study
everyone's different there's you know
you're asking me you know by the nature
of an interview you're asking me
questions that are less broadly
applicable hopefully as they can be and
you know what's true Susan Cain or JK
Rowling or this one or that one is not
going to be true for 90% of the audience
you know but but yeah I mean the thing
about a Susan Cain and certain others is
they kept genuinely enhancing and
improving and putting more meat on the
bone Susan didn't waste the last three
years out of those seven years just
cuddling her manuscript right what that
wasn't her process but but most people
who spend seven years on anything I can
almost guarantee you have wasted a lot
of time right
it's very individual well just wrapping
up just quickly you'd said something
earlier about you know the person who's
too grandiose versus then the person who
thinks that they everyone else knows
more than they and David and I happen to
be having a very similar conversation in
the car about how there's just got
almost like two types of people and I've
said it before in interviews but finding
that middle ground because you oh you
know the braggart you know the one
that's this is the next best thing and
that person is usually had a cocktail
party and that's the one you move away
from and then you know the one that
probably has a lot of really interesting
things to say but you can't get it out
of them because they don't believe in
themselves and they're closed off their
arms are closed and it's almost like
they want to go into a corner so how do
we how do we find that middle balance
cuz I think a lot of times these
personality types don't know that they
are that way and I think if you could
take that braggart and make them a
little more take them down on the scale
rather take the quiet one and make them
talk a little more make them more
grandiose yeah cuz I can guarantee it
the the person who's and we I get this a
lot you know and here's the good news
it's not just a script it's a trilogy
and guess what I've already figured out
the merchandising and guess what it's
guaranteed to make a hundred million
dollars at the box office you are so
lucky but I'm offering you this project
it's like please get out of my Inbox
that's never gonna happen
I remember Lilly Tartikoff
after Brandon Tartikoff died who was
almost unparalleled in for who he was
and how people embraced him he was
beloved everything about him his
intelligence his creativity his
personality his very down to earth quiet
ways charming and created the most
successful Network in the history of
television and brought more innovation
to to bear than anyone who had come
before
and I remember Lilly Tartikoff in an
interview talking about she was sitting
she met him at this big party I think
was it Lew Wasserman or some some big
persons home and everybody else was very
you know in the moment and there was
this one guy very quiet guy off in the
corner sort of keeping to himself really
not talking and she just zeroed in on
him and said that's the one right and
whenever and met him and sure enough
right
jf Lawton was the same way I met lot not
because he was a writer I hired him to
program my Macintosh which was you know
like in the mid 80s it was one of the
first ones and he you couldn't plug the
sucker it didn't do anything and a
writer friend of mine happened to use
the Mac and I asked how did you who
program that and she said this guy I
called this guy and it was jf Lawton he
literally sat by my side worked in my
office non-stop for three weeks
programming learning everything about my
life what I did how I did it what I
wanted and what I needed he knew
everything about it so he knew my work
but he never mentioned that he was a
writer he had seven scripts sitting in
his little one-room studio he was that
quiet brilliant shy guy who was just he
was so gifted it was ridiculous but you
had to pull it out of him
and I did but you have to sort of just
notice things you know there's there's
this wonderful Daniel Goleman who wrote
emotional intelligence gave a talk and
he talks about I forgot what camps it
was a campus back East somewhere in the
United States where they have a seminary
as well and they did an experiment and
in this experiment they divided the
seminary students into two groups and
they told both groups that they were
going to develop and deliver that same
day a sermon but to the control group a
they said on any topic of your choosing
but to control Group B they said you're
going to deliver a sermon based on the
parable of the Good Samaritan well we
all know the parable of Israel so they
were both sent off to to spend a certain
amount of time crafting their sermon and
after a certain amount of time they were
told okay it's time to leave we're gonna
go to the chapel
which is the far side of the campus and
then we're gonna walk these curving
walkways across campus to the to the
chapel and so they did but along the
path right off the walkway on the lawn
writhing in fetal position was a
somewhat older man obviously in bad
shape in pain
the study was to see how many and which
students stopped and why and those who
didn't stop why didn't I stop one would
logically think that those who stock
were the ones who were writing the
parable about the parable of the Good
Samaritan because that was their mindset
but that wasn't it all true what was
true I said of those who stopped and
those who didn't
there was one consistent reality the
students who did not feel prepared who
are anxious who were consumed who were
not ready to deliver their sermon who
were lost in their thoughts about what
am I gonna do they didn't notice this
person on the ground they literally
didn't notice and so they continued
along the walkway the students who felt
ready confident self-contained about
this idea they walked and they were
observing and noticing everything around
them because they were free and present
and they noticed this man on the ground
writhing in pain and they stopped had
nothing to do with the Good Samaritan it
had to do with the fact that we in the
modern age notice so much less because
we're so busy on so many levels that we
miss a lot of life we miss opportunity
we must people we miss community we miss
so much just because we don't notice
I would say there's this there's there's
a lesson in there for those who aspire
to afraid of career but I wouldn't say
that to them
[Laughter]